Sen
[Müzik]
Ankara'da mı
ne oluyor okuldan sonra şeyler yiyor
lazım gidiyorum genelde
gidiyorum
arkadaşlar bu da
[Müzik]
bu
silahları
isten sonra
[Müzik]
da artık hafta sonu
lazım mı
[Müzik]
bu
dünyadan konuş ya
[Müzik]
Evet tamam
son olarak
görüyorum o
[Müzik]
ne
diyor o zaman
bunlara koyacağız istiyorum şimdi bir
arttırma yapıyorum yersiniz bir
araştırma
araştırma o
[Müzik]
of of Önce ağzına daha fazla Oğlum
neredesin
uzmanına göre 125 daha fazla olduğunda
bu
yollarını
çalışmalar
yapmaya öğrenci o
[Müzik]
bu oluşma
nasılsın ayrı mı yoksa zaman mı
[Müzik]
ne
yaptın İyi bakalım
[Müzik]
görüşürüz o
o rüyadan sonra oluşmuş şu şekilde bir
şey bekliyorum
[Müzik]
size Kendinizden bahseder ya
ne
yaptık sosyal olarak ne olabilir ki
[Müzik]
Ne konuşacağız bu
Evet şimdi
lazım Oha lan zaman yapmaya başladım
zaman
gittim bizde
yalan yok
[Müzik]
abone ol
bu yavruları okulu
Yaz
[Müzik]
Çocuklar da çıkıyor
çalışacağız tek başımayım
bu şifa olsun
çıkarma çevirdim bağlanıyor ya bu
şekilde ezberledim anlatıyorsun ya
[Müzik]
O zaman sen yanlış
yapmışsın onu hallettim ama
budabenimolsun sorunsuz geçio acıma da
olmaz zamanlarda
çocuklar
zaman o
[Müzik]
bu
yakıcısı
alabileceğim bir şey var mı bu
ayağımızın
ettiğin zaman olduğu için bazılarını
geçiyorum
ağlamak istiyorum aslında spor mı
[Müzik]
Allah razı olsun
sağ ol yolculuğa çıkacağız birlikte bir
hayal oldu
bu
akşam var mı
o vahim giyindin okula gideceksiniz aynı
sınavımız var
okula gittiğimiz
Arkadaşlarınıza bir
[Müzik]
mı
Bir dakika çizgi film
izlemeye gelmiş aynısını arkadaşım
biliyor o sırada o
[Müzik]
Sağ
olasınız eve geldim yeni geliriz
birazdan o